Marvel's Doctor Strange had the enormous
task of introducing big magic to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
you know same reality of Captain America
and Iron Man and other science-based
heroes even Scarlet Witch is explained
as using cosmic energy when she does her
thing so Doctor Strange explore some
weird new places for our heroes and fans
and critics agree that it does so really
really well but despite having a
compelling story and mind-blowing
visuals to boot the film still had a few
head scratchers that you couldn't just
wave a magic wand at here are a few plot
points that not even Stephen strange
could explain missing magicians when
strange is going through his training at
Kumar Taj there are a boatload of other
would-be Wizards taking on the same
drills and learning the same magic
alongside him it's a whole wizard army
just ready to be set loose on any
mystical threat ranging from cassellius
to David Blaine so where were all these
folks when cassellius attacked the
sanctums the ancient one knows that the
bad guy is going to try and take out the
sanctums so why is only one dude hanging
out all by himself as a defender they
have the numbers to set up a platoon of
wizards that each sanctum encase have
been assault even if those trainees
don't yet have full-on magic mojo yet a
lack of training has never stopped
fellow baldie professor axe from
throwing kids at the bad guys it's never
stopped Batman and it shouldn't have
stopped an all-out war against castilian
only the surface like most big
blockbusters Marvel movies have never
been afraid of clunky product placement
just ask everyone in Civil War about
their weird vevo phones in dr. strange
things are a bit more subtle but one
noticeable little moment sticks out like
a sore thumb
strange is a world-renowned doctor and
he's pretty banged it he doesn't skimp
on the cars that he had Hazzard Lee
drives around mountains and his
extravagant New York City apartment must
cost millions so why does Steven strange
use a surface 3 tablet the surface 3 is
basically the toyota corolla of the
computer world it's fine but it's far
from the best if you have an unlimited
budget strange couldn't even spring for
a surface pro that's weak stuff doc
chain-gang the movie kicks off with
castelia stealing spells from the
library at Kumar Taj in order to summon
Dormammu it's clear that these books are
extremely dangerous and they're only
protected by some blues James
it's basically level 1
wizard stuff to make a portal so it's
clear that the chains aren't there for
protection that's why they have
librarians which seems to be the most
dangerous job in the whole joint
after the initial head shopping scene
with chairman Wang in the library
protecting the book unfortunately Wang
isn't you know great at his job
[Music]
technically no knowledge is forbidden
and kamar Tosh but when it being so
crazy to protect these books a little
better obviously a regular vault
wouldn't be immune to wizard portals
grabby hands or even your standard
Hamburglar but these guys have the most
powerful magic on earth at their
disposal there's got to be a magic force
field spell in one of these books right
sometimes the honor system doesn't work
okay Deus Ex Magica it's hard to
overlook the film's most absurd
coincidence Doctor Strange dives into a
book all about time manipulation only
moments before cassellius attacks it's
perfect timing in the worst possible way
where the heck is Co silly has been
during all this time while strangest
training castelia steals the pages for
his spell in the first moments of the
movie then wait months the stage his
next attack all he did was allow the
ancient one more time to plan train
strange and beefed up their defenses
which they kind of failed at anyhow
time and time again Mordo spends most of
the moving warning strange over and over
about messing around with time noting it
can result in everything from the end of
the world to severe constipation
temporal manipulations can create
branches in time unstable dimensional
openings special paradoxes time loops
but later strange uses the eye of
agamotto to rewind downtown Hong Kong to
a time before the local thank them falls
in an effort to save the day he then
cleverly mucks around with a time loop
to stop Dormammu in his tracks
I come too far
mama-mama if messing around with an
apple was dangerous
you think erasing the destruction of an
entire city is flirting with all-out
cosmic disaster right but after all
those warnings for more dough there are
no immediate consequences for Strange's
actions everything seems fine even still
more dough it seems to know what's up
you still think there will be no
consequences strange no price to pay but
let's see infinity war try to write
itself around legette time-travel magic
more dough Toria by the end of the film
mortos got a brand new bag his mission
is to go around and take magic away from
people who use it since too much
unchecked magic honestly seems like a
pretty bad idea so more token errantly
just take away magic now that ability
sheer would have come in handy a bit
earlier you know when the dude with all
the magic power was straight-up trying
to end the entire world
unless of course more dough can only
suck the magic out of low-level
Dumbledore's like the guy with the spine
problems which is a pretty crappy magic
trick it's the magic equivalent of
stepping on bug I mean it's pointless
and it only feels good if your jerk
Mordo should pick on someone his own
power level guess we'll have to wait for
dr. strange to magic house call for that
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to